the yad vashem or world Holocaust
Remembrance Center commemorates non-jews
who took great risks to save Jews during
the show ha with the title of Righteous
among the Nations today's protagonist is
one of them Cornelia 10 bomb known as
Corrie and a close family they managed
to save an estimated 800 lives during
the Nazi occupation of the Netherlands
during the war her profound religious
faith and belief in God's plans gave her
the bravery and resourceful nough stew
make it through situations was worthy of
a spy story but it was after the war
that she achieved her greatest
accomplishments forgiving her former
enemies and teaching the world to do the
same Cornelia R Naza Janet n bomb was
born in Harlem near Amsterdam on the
15th of April 1892 in a devoutly
religious family her father Casper was a
watchmaker who ran the business from
their own home the Bear house Corrie was
the youngest of four siblings her sister
Betsy and nolle and her brother vilem
her mother grocer named Cornelia and her
father were members of the Dutch Baptist
congregation and a point of moral
reference for the community inspired by
their faith the ten bombs would offer
shelter food and even money to those in
need they also maintained very good
relationships with the local Jewish
community whom they considered God's
ancient people Corrie was always a busy
girl helping those in need both in and
outside her family from a very young age
she and Betsy organized Bible clubs for
the local youth and offered tutoring to
mentally disabled children when her
elderly aunts moved in she still found
the time to look after them to make
space for our arms Caspar bought the
house next to the bay the levels of the
two buildings did not match and there
was an alleyway between them but the two
houses they had to be connected this
resulted in a very odd layout with
winding staircases and empty spaces
between walls gonna see in a moment why
this is actually important in her late
teens Corrie met and fell in love for
the first time with a young man she was
expecting him to propose but his mother
did not approve of the union deeming the
ten bombs of lower social status her
heart was broken and she vowed to
dedicate all of her love for Jesus but
as she pointed out Jesus
taking care of me that I have never
become a frustrated old spinster in 1918
mother 10 bond became bedridden from a
cerebral hemorrhage this added to
Corey's long list of commitments bitter
energy at never failed her she dedicated
herself to doing all of the housework
and even managing the family's business
she studied watchmaking becoming the
first licensed dutch woman watchmaker
unlike caspere he wasn't very business
minded Corey had a keen commercial sense
and with management's of the shop the
family did better financially
unfortunately after three years of
illness Cory's mother died in 1921 the
elderly aunts also passed away shortly
before with an empty house and plenty of
spare time corriander family they took
the occasion to help people once again
first they started welcoming the
children left in the Netherlands by
missionaries travelling to the
Indonesian colonies then over much of
the 1930s Corey established a youth club
for teenagers where she taught religious
studies as well as performing arts and
handicrafts
unfortunately for her than for the
Netherlands and for Europe over the
border in Germany another type of youth
club was gaining grounds Europe in the
whole world were heading towards another
war but most people in the Netherlands
including the Prime Minister believes
look Germany would respect Dutch
neutrality as was the case in World War
one what they didn't know is that
general von Manstein's planned to invade
France relied on an initial attack
through the Netherlands in order to
divert Allied forces from the real main
invading force entering Belgium via the
Ardennes Forest and so after conquering
Poland Denmark and Norway the German
military started to turn their attention
towards the Western Allied powers the
phoney war was about to give way to the
actual one on the 10th of May 1940 the
veer marked launched a combined attack
on the Netherlands supported by frequent
bombing raids on major Dutch cities one
night Corey was woken up by the noise of
bombers flying over Harlem she stood up
and went into the kitchen where Betsy
unable to sleep off at her some tea when
Corey returned to her room she had her
hands on something sharp it was a piece
of shrapnel from a bomb that had
exploded nearby the morning after she
pointed out to Betsy that if she had not
drunk tea with her the night before she
could have been killed
the oldest sister remarked there are no
ifs with God being in the center of his
will is our only safety despite a
desperate resistance German divisions
quickly overrun the country
on the 13th of May the Dutch government
and the royal family they were evacuated
to Britain on the 14th the country
capitulated the Nazi occupation it was
harsh from the very beginning with the
Gestapo starting to round up Jews and
resistance fighters with the help of
local collaborators as well as
confiscating all radios the ten bombs
managed to keep a clandestine wireless
listening to messages of hope coming
from the BBC and from the Dutch Queen in
exile in London they also listen to some
of Hitler's propaganda speeches as Coria
remembered it was the voice of a demon
Caspar 10 Baum was a pillar of the
Harlem community and so very soon his
family was approached by resistance
fighters and Jewish citizens asking for
help
Caspar Corey and Betsy they faced a
dilemma their faith compelled them to
protect Jews but being a part of the
resistance implied taking a political
stance which was against their beliefs
the doubts were wiped out by two events
first Cory found out that her brother
Villa and his son Kirk had already
entered the clandestine resistance and
were already offering shelter to Jews on
the run even before the invasion velum
had used a nursing home that he was
managing as a haven for German Jews who
had fled persecution then Caspar heard
about a local pastor who was refused to
hide a Jewish orphan boy he decided to
welcome the boy into the house the first
of many lives up to 800 that the temples
would save during a war Cory had a knack
for organizing people around her she
soon put this talent to fruition when
she recruited 80 of the members of the
various youth and Bible groups to what
became a very effective clandestine
organization taking advantage of the
uncommon layout of the bear and with the
help of an architect in the resistance
Cory had a secret room a hiding place
built behind a fake wall in her own
bedroom the place could hide six people
at a time she also had a system of
buzzes installed around the house in
case of danger a family member would
ring the buzzes allowing the refugees to
rush to the secret room where they would
stand still and silent when the coast
was clear the refugees would be sent to
a vast - network of safe houses around
the country until they could flee abroad
on one occasion the ten bombs heard that
the Nazis had set their sights on a
Jewish orphanage dozens of babies were
facing certain death
Cory organized a daring raid among the
people she helped were also German
soldiers deserters who did not want to
carry out further atrocities the ten
bombs would give them civilian clothing
and keep their uniforms in this case
Corey handed out the uniforms to members
of her organization wearing this
disguise they simply entered the
orphanage and took 100 babies as the
number of people they helps increase the
family had to solve the problem of
feeding them food was rationed through a
system of cards which the ten bonds held
only three by luck or divine providence
that okhla man in charge of the ration
cards was one fred Kunz drew whose
mentally disabled daughter had been
attending Corey's church services for
twenty years
Cory was not sure if she could trust him
but she boldly asked for a hundred
ration cards to her surprise Fred agreed
immediately but how could he justify a
hundred missing cards to his Nazi
supervisor
in a stroke of genius
red staged a realistic robbery even
asking a friend beat him up to make you
look more plausible the clandestine
activities around Corey's house
increased with time despite the threat
of the Gestapo being ever-present and a
police station being only a few blocks
away as Corey feared that their phone
was tapped she devised a secret code the
sentence I need a watch to be repaired
and that another person needed hiding
the watchmaker shop was now a perfect
front for people coming and going at all
times
Kasper also devised another coat a
triangular advertising sign on the shop
window that meant it was safe to come in
if it was placed back to front it meant
that it was better to wait in February
1944 a man called Yann Vogel came asking
for a different type of help his wife
accused of being in the resistance was
in custody a sympathetic policeman had
promised free her but had requested a
bribe of 600 guilders Yann did not have
the money and he asked the ten bombs for
a loan the following day at 5:00 a.m.
the ten bombs were holding a Bible
reading with many family members and
friends from the community attending
alongside six refugees the doorbell rang
when Betsey opened the door she was
pushed aside by a Nazi officer other
soldiers burst in led by Vogel
he was a collaborator Betsy was able to
hit one of the buzzes and the six
refugees for Jews and two resistance
fighters ran to Corey's bedroom while
the soldiers were negotiating the
strange layout of the house making their
way upwards Cory was able to hide the
refugees behind the fake wall she later
commented that the uncommon floor plans
of the house were another sign of God's
providence which had come to help her in
a predicament
the Nazis accused her of hiding Jews
hitting her repeatedly but she kept her
mouth shut
the soldiers they searched the house and
they couldn't find the secret room one
of them was out saying if there is a
secret room here the devil himself built
it corabeth seen Casper were arrested
alongside 30 other friends and taken to
Chafin in a prison as Cory was ill with
pleurisy she was put in solitary
confinement to prevent a contagion one
day in her lonely cell Cory received a
letter from her sister Molly who was
still freed the letter bore the sad news
that Casper her elderly father had died
10 days into his imprisonment Cory had
not seen him since the day they arrived
in prison it was devastating for Cory to
learn that her father who had been the
moral guiding light
to her and so many other people in
Harlem was no more
despite the grief there was some good
news though Couric noticed that the
address on the envelope slanted towards
the stamp curious tree unpeeled it and
found a secret message it read all the
watchers are safe a code phrase meaning
that all of their Jewish guests were out
of hiding and still alive Corey had
little time to grieve as she was
summoned for interrogation the first
hearing was with the German officer ray
leftenant ROMs the officer was polite
albeit dismissive of Corey's activism in
supporting and protecting the mentally
disabled seen as undesirables by the
Reich caring for them was a waste of
energy as one more person is worth all
the half-wits in the world
twitch curry replied in God's eyes one
half-wit mighty worth more than a
watchmaker or a left-handed the next
interrogator was a dutch judge
collaborating with the german
authorities in Corey's own words her
faith touched him and he became a friend
but this friend still had to do his job
the judge produced some documents found
to house a list of names and addresses
which would immediately incriminate her
remaining family members and resistance
friends who were still at large the
judge remarked how dangerous those
papers were to the safety of the
organization that she had set up then
without adding a word he simply turned
to his stove opened up the door and
threw them into the flames after three
months Corey was finally taken out of
confinement and reunited with her
beloved sister Betsy there was no hope
to be set free though as they and all
other prisoners were loaded onto cattle
trains and sent to the Dutch labor camp
of vote where they were forced to make
radios for the Luftwaffe then the 6th of
June 1944 arrived d-day as the Allies
pushed their way towards blond as the
Nazis decided to empty their camps in
the Netherlands and relocate the
prisoners to Germany Corey and Betsy
ended up in ravensbrück the infamous
camp for women prisoners
the experience in the concentration camp
was hellish Carrie Betsey and the other
prisoners were subjected to endless days
of labour starvation illness and abuse
by the guards and yet every night the
two sisters would find the time and
energy to organize prayer groups in
their barracks with the help of a
smuggled Bible every night this would
give the incarcerated women some peace
some faith and hope and every night Cory
and Betsey they feared an inspection
from the guards while knowing that
Bibles and prayer were forbidden in the
camp but in another stroke of luck or
maybe divine intervention worded spreads
that their barracks was flea infested
and so the wardens they kept a safe
distance in the late autumn Betsy fell
ill during this time she'd discussed
with Corey a vision that she had a plan
to heal the wounds of the suffering in
post-war Europe first they were going to
set up a sort of rehabilitation centre
in the Netherlands to provide support
for those who had suffered during the
war and the centre also had to be open
to Nazi collaborators so as to reform
them and reintegrate them into society
then Corey and Betsy would proceed to
help the German people as well as it was
clear that their country was going to be
devastated that's he even had a mental
image of a former concentration camp
painted in green and converted into a
Welcome Center
let's see though she wouldn't live to
see her vision she died on the 16th of
December 1944 now alone and losing hope
on the morning of the 28th of December
Corrie was summoned to the commander's
office and asked to fill in some forms
and were simply released
she later discovered that this was due
to a clerical error and that only a week
later all of the women her age had been
taken to the gas chambers
the war had taken a huge toll on the 10
bombs
Kaspar Betsy and brother Willem were
dead Willems son kick was missing in
action quarry though she would not
surrender she immediately resumed her
work with mentally disabled children but
most of all she carried out Betsy's
vision her plan for reconciliation as
she was setting up a home to
rehabilitate former collaborators she
received a letter from the man who had
betrayed her and her family
Yann Vogel awaiting a death sentence
John had risen to quarry asking if she
could forgive him she could and she did
this was the first of many acts of
forgiveness for her old enemies and
tremendous continuing Betsy's vision
Cori moved to Germany and succeeded in
gaining management of an ex
concentration camp in Darmstadt as per
her sister's wishes she had all of the
buildings painted bright green and
flowers planted around the houses the
old site of death became a housing scent
of a German families that were left
homeless by the Allied bombing raids
Cori also started to tour churches from
the Netherlands to Germany giving talks
about her experiences in ravans Brook on
one such occasion she noticed a man
sitting at the back of the room who
would not meet her gaze she then
recognized him he was a former guard at
the concentration camp one who had been
particularly cruel to her sister
he had become a Christian and was now
looking for forgiveness he stretched out
his hand Cori initially could not accept
it the memories of the man's cruelties
were still strong but she remembers from
the Bible this hatred means murder in
God's eyes she was able to forgive the
former guard this act would inspire her
to continue her tours relating her
experience and preaching the power of
forgiveness of your enemies this was a
powerful and courageous idea one cannot
deny that the Nuremberg trials were what
Nazi war criminals deserved and yet the
idea of private forgiveness can coexist
with the notion of public justice as
philosopher Paula Ricker put it
forgiveness is not amnesty amnesty is
organized forgetting and it has nothing
to do with the pacification that
forgiveness can bring between two
consciousnesses in the 1960s Khoury
moved to the United States to spread her
messages across congregations of all
faiths she was penniless and lived
frugally all the publicity she could
afford was to go from one church to
another and ask if the community was
interested in hearing a story little by
little people started to take
of this elderly lady her array Cherie
style and to values her admirers
suggested that she write a book about
her experience the hiding place was
published in 1971 followed by a film
adaptation in 1975 Khoury continued to
receive more and more invitations to
speak worldwide but she had to slow down
her engagements due to declining health
one morning in 1978 curry did not wake
up at dawn as usual her assistants and
friends Pam rose well Moore went to wake
her up as it was uncommon for Cory to
oversleep in the mornings Pam found out
that during the night Cory had had a
cerebral vascular stroke from which she
did not recover for the following five
years she was paralyzed unable to talk
read and write finally on the day of her
91st birthday the 15th of April 8 1981
Corrie ten Boom died peacefully
according to Jewish tradition only those
who are specially blessed by God granted
the privilege of dying on the same day
as their birthday so I really hope you
found that video interesting we'd love
to hear your thoughts please do use the
comments below for that also please
don't forget to subscribe and like this
video and all of that good stuff
and as always I'll see you next time